ukraine's deputy prime minister says
seven humanitarian corridors are planned
for the besieged cities of ukraine today
and the red cross is making a fresh push
to remove residents from the ruins of
mariopol for weeks the port city has
been under siege by russian forces
estimates say more than 150 000 people
are trapped in desperate circumstances
and exposed to constant shelling
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
said on friday some people did manage to
escape against the odds
arriving to relative safety
after weeks of shelling
over three thousand were able to escape
mariopol on friday
but it's a journey full of
risks one woman recounts her fears as
she crossed a russian checkpoint
it was very difficult she said
i was afraid they would take my son away
they made him throw his phone on the
ground and trample on it because he had
american music
an attempt by the red cross to deliver
aid and evacuate civilians
ended in failure
the organization said the lives of
thousands
depended on evacuations
there is no plan b here we have been
working for weeks uh and telling the
media about our efforts to
get into mario paul with aid and to
allow the safe passage of civilians out
of the city
um
time is running out for the people of
mario paul
they are desperately in need of
assistance and they are desperately need
of leaving the city if they wish to do
so
unable to wait
others fled the bombs in cars
the white cloth a sign they mean no harm
as many as a hundred and seventy
thousand are still trapped in this city
that's been devastated by war
this former orphanage
now a makeshift bomb shelter
for those who can't escape
the red cross said they will attempt
once again to reach the city on saturday
in a bid to rescue the innocent
from what is left of mariopol
and joining us now is maria sirichenko
former resident of marielle paul who is
now sheltering in levi in western
ukraine maria welcome back to dw news uh
over the past month you've been giving
us regular updates on what you've been
hearing from the port city and now some
of your friends and family we understand
have managed to get out what did they
tell you
uh hi thanks for having me yeah most of
my close people my relatives and friends
managed to escape the city and they
share horrible terrifying stories of
their weeks
under constant shelling with no food no
hate no power and no access to any
information they are very afraid
and
as incredible as it may seem thousands
of people are trying to escape pretty
much everybody but some people
we're told are trying to
return and i understand you actually
have a friend who tried to go back
yeah
my close friend
she didn't find her parents in the city
and she couldn't find a way how to
vacate them with the volunteers because
as you know there is no humanitarian
help and no
corridors
nothing for people to advocate so she
decided to go there on her own
and try to find her parents and vacate
them unfortunately i have no connection
with her for three or four days already
so i don't know where she is right now
but i hope that she managed to find her
parents and get them out of the city of
that help
and um and we hope so too of course
listen the the city as we've been saying
is being shelled non-stop um much lies
in ruin i think a lot of our viewers
will remember that maternity ward uh
that was uh came under artillery barrage
and the theater that was destroyed which
was sheltering people
do you think despite the devastation
that people once peace comes will want
to go back to that city
well it's a very hard question because
this is our home even despite the uh
constant shelling and all the ruins that
are currently there but you can imagine
that for instance in my yard there are
graves now so um i can't imagine uh when
we can go back there and uh we will need
to rebuild the city
and invest you know billions of dollars
to rebuild the houses and the uh
infrastructure but
unfortunately thousands of people have
already died and no one can return that
so
i'm i hope that
we will be able to return and marupal
will be
a ukrainian city um
would
prosper and everything again so
um i have a dream to get back to my home
okay maria sirichenko
former resident of mario paul thank you
so much for sharing those harrowing
stories and and your dream
thank you
dw correspondent amnesia joins us live
now from the ukrainian city of la vie
and the west of the country i mean tell
us about these attempts to rescue the
residents of mario paul would you
since thursday now red cross buses
in under the direction of the ukrainian
government have been trying to bring
much needed aid food medical supplies
into that besieged city of marijuana and
to fill those buses with residents and
bring them out of there there's an
estimated 170 000 people in that city
falling victim every day to russian
shelling and fighting in the streets
so far the mass evacuations have failed
but we have heard the good news that
residents who were fit enough and lucky
enough to find their own rides out of
the city to the neighboring city of
bardians also on the sea of azov that
they were able to take buses from there
to the safer region of zaparija or to
just continue along those humanitarian
corridors to a safer space but as i said
the mass evacuation of thousands of
civilians that needs to happen in order
to save their lives has not happened yet
and those that attempt is going to
continue until it's no longer possible
and in that story we heard about the
fear that some refugees are feeling at
russian checkpoints uh why are there any
credible reports of russian soldiers
mistreating them
there's uh several reports of
not only mishandling but situations
where as civilians pass through a
checkpoint after they've cleared the
checkpoint then they come under fire
from russian troops that we've also
heard stories of people being abducted
when they go through checkpoints
journalists and activists who are then
forcibly brought to russia and no longer
heard of colleagues here have talked to
family members who have had that happen
to their family members
we've also heard that mines have been
placed on roads leading out of dangerous
areas like mario pole and many people
driving over those mines at night fall
victim to them injuries and deaths so
the danger of fleeing to safety is
sometimes greater than that of staying
in the city at least that's how some
people are calculating it nick well it
sounds like an incredibly dire situation
um just to talk about the politics here
president zielinski has made a statement
and what he expects russia will do next
can you give us the main points
he's basically warned ukrainians to
remain cautious as they move back into
areas that russia has left after they've
decided to redeploy troops to the east
so leve where i am western ukraine is
considered a safer area in the country
lots of ex-residents of kiev live here
and there's been talk in the last few
days of us
starting their lives again in kiev now
that russian troops have mainly moved
out of the areas surrounding the capital
city but what zelensky warned is that as
russian troops leave they've left a
disaster behind them he's warned of
shelling continuing there from afar he's
also warned of russian troops leaving
minds uh for people who move back into
the area just as an act of terrorism
even mining uh bodies or rubble so that
when people come to remove dead bodies
from the street or to
pull away rubble then they could fall
victim to a mine that was placed there
so all in all he said that
as it becomes safer to move into these
areas people still need to remain highly
cautious and and vigilant as they try to
begin their lives again
okay dw correspondent amin isif
thanks for that
you